>> Kat: THE DOLLAR'S VALUE IS
REDUCING WHICH HURTS PEOPLE
REPRODUCING.
YOU'LL FACE FINANCIAL HURDLES IF
YOU'RE REALLY FERTILE.
THANKS TO SOARING INFLATION IT
NOW COSTS $300,000 TO RAISE A
CHILD.
OR $50 FOR AN UBER TO DROP ONE
OFF AT THE FIRE DEPARTMENT.
I THOUGHT THIS WAS AMERICA.
ANYWAY, THIS IS ALL ACCORDING TO
FIGURES FROM THE BROOKINGS
INSTITUTION AND PUBLISHED IN THE
WALL STREET JOURNAL WHICH OF
COURSE IS OWNED BY OUR PARENT
COMPANY CHUCK E. CHEESE.
THEY ESTIMATE THAT A MARRIED
MIDDLE INCOME COUPLE WITH A KID
BORN IN 2015 WOULD SPEND ABOUT
18 GRAND A YEAR TO RAISE THE KID
JUST THROUGH HIGH SCHOOL.
THAT COVERS HOUSING, FOOD,
CLOTHES, HEALTHCARE AND
RECREATION BUT IT ONLY GETS THE
KID THROUGH THE AGE OF 17 AND
DOES NOT INCLUDE PIANO LESSONS
DANCE LESSONS OR BAIL.
SO IF YOU WANT TO SEND HIM TO
COLLEGE, MAYBE DON'T.
LIKE WHY SHOULD THE KID GET TO
PARTY ON YOUR DIME FOR FOUR
YEARS.
I SAY USE THAT MONEY INSTEAD TO
THROW SOME RAGERS OF YOUR OWN!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Kat: GET DRUNK, THROW UP ON
THE DOG, SPRAY-PAINT YOUR
NEIGHBOR'S CAR.
EITHER WAY YOU MIGHT BE GLAD YOU
SPENT THAT HARD-EARNED CASH ON
YOURSELF.
ALTHOUGH BY THE TIME THEY GET TO
COLLEGE, WHO KNOWS WHERE IT WILL
BE ANYWAY.
AN NBC NEWS POLL FINDS 74% HAVE
AMERICANS SAY THE COUNTRY'S
HEADED IN THE WRONG DIRECTION
AND JUST 42% APPROVE OF THE JOB
PRESIDENT BESIDE'S DOING.
FOR CONTACT EVEN JIMMY'S HIDEOUS
JACKET POLLS AT AROUND 43%.
SO, MR. PRESIDENT, WHAT GIVES?
>> HEY, I GET IT, I GET IT.
YOU KNOW, IT'S TOUGH RAISING
KIDS.
IT'S EXPENSIVE.
I KNOW THAT.
BUT IT PAYS OFF IN THE LONG RUN.
YEAH, LIKE I DID WITH HUNTER.
HE HAD A COUPLE WILD OATS TO SEW
BUT THEN I SENT HIM OVER TO THAT
COUNTRY.
WHAT IS IT CALLED?
BURISMA.
HE DID OKAY FOR HIMSELF AND
THREW A COUPLE POTATOES MY WAY
AS WELL SO THAT DIDN'T HURT.
SO, YOU KNOW, I'M PLAYING THE
LONG GAME, MAN.
I'M LIKE THAT GUY, WHAT'S HIS
NAME?
THE GUY WHO PLAYS THE LONG GAME?
I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T CARE.
ALL THAT MATTERS I'M THE SENATOR
FROM THE GREAT STATE OF
DELAWARE.
I'M THE VICE-PRESIDENT.
I'M THE PRESIDENT.
SHUT UP.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Kat: OH, BOY.
JIMMY, I'VE MET YOUR KIDS
>> Jimmy: THE LINK MAN.
>> Kat: IS HE WORTH 300 GRAND?
I DON'T KNOW.
>> Jimmy: I DON'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT SAVING FOR COLLEGE FOR TWO
REASONS WITH LINCOLN.
ONE IS OBVIOUSLY HIS GRADES,
OKAY, IT'S OUT OF THE QUESTION.
BUT, NO, I HAVE A SON, I HAVE A
SON WHICH MEANS HE CAN GET A
WOMAN'S BASKETBALL SCHOLARSHIP.
THE KID IS 6'5", I HAVE A 6'5"
THROB YEAR OLD.
HE'S GOING TO GET A SCHOLARSHIP
>> Douglas: DOES HE KNOW THAT'S
YOUR PLAN FOR HIM.
>> Kat: HE DOES NOW.
>> Jimmy: I WENT TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND I KNOW IT SHOWS A
LOT ON THE AIR BUT THE POINT IS,
WE ARE OVER EMPHASIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF COLLEGE NUMBER ONE
BUT NUMBER TWO LIKE YOU SAID THE
DIRECTION THE COUNTRY'S GOING
IN, WE'RE HEADING INTO EVERYBODY
FOR THEMSELVES.
YOU LOOK LIKE A PRESIDENCY LIKE
AN UBER RIDE.
75% OF THE PASSENGERS SAY THE
DRIVER'S GOING DOWN A ONE WAY,
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
AND THAT'S BEEN THE WHOLE
ADMINISTRATION AS A HOLE.
IF YOU EVER SAT IN THE SA LAN
FOR A BAD HAIR CUT, I HAVE.
YOU KNOW HOW IT STARTS, WHAT'S
HE DOING DOWN THE SIDE, THERE'S
TOO MUCH ON THE TOP.
THAT'S THE PRESIDENCY, WHAT'S HE
DOING ON THE BOARDER?
OH MY GOD LOOK AT INFLATION.
AND THEN YOU GET UP AND GO I'M
NEVER COMING HERE AGAIN.
>> Kat: TYRUS, DO YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS RAISING KIDS IN THIS
ECONOMY?
>> Tyrus: PAY YOUR [BLEEP] ON
TIME.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Tyrus: I DON'T KNOW WHO THEY
POLLED BECAUSE MY MOTHER RACED
ME AND MY BROTHER ON LIKE $45
AND SOME HAND ME DOWNS.
SO IT USED TO BE A SAYING, YOU
MAKE A DOLLAR OUT OF $0.15.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THESE PARENTS
ARE BUYING.
YOU KNOW, IT MUST BE ALL THE
APPLE CARDS AND ROADBLOCK CARDS
AND ET CETERA, BULLDOZER PARENTS
RAISE A LOT OF MONEY.
I STILL RAISE MY KIDS THE WAY MY
MOM RACED ME.
"NO."
.
>> Kat: YEAH.
>> Tyrus: YOU KNOW?
TRY NO.
BUT, REAL QUICK, THE REASON WHY
PEOPLE SAY THE COUNTRY'S GOING
THE OTHER WAY, WHEN YOU HAVE AN
ADMINISTRATION WHOSE ONLY
VICTORIES ARE CHANGING NAMES AND
ADDING GENDERS, THAT DOESN'T
REALLY HELP WITH ANYTHING ELSE.
IN THE LATEST ONE THEY SAID THAT
IT WAS PREGNANT PERSON, REMEMBER
THAT BRILLIANT IDEA.
THEN THEY DECIDED TO CHANGE
THEIR MIND AND LET US KNOW THAT
IT'S GOING TO GO BACK TO
PREGNANT WOMAN, AS IF EVERYBODY
UP THERE CHANGED.
IT WAS UP THERE WITH NEW COKE
AND CNN PLUS, PREGNANT PERSON.
SO THAT'S PROBABLY WHY PEOPLE
ARE A LITTLE CONCERNED THE WAY
THINGS ARE GOING.
>> Kat: DOUGLAS, IT IS
CONCERNING, I THINK THE NUMBER'S
ALWAYS TOO HIGH OF THE PEOPLE.
LIKE WHO ARE THESE PEOPLE, YEAH,
THE 41 WHO THINKS THINGS ARE
GOING GREAT
>> Douglas: WHERE DO THEY FIND
THEM?
>> Kat: I DON'T KNOW.
>> Tyrus: SHOW YOURSELF.
>> Kat: YEAH
>> Douglas: WHENEVER THESE
FIGURES COME OUT ABOUT HOW MUCH
IT COSTS TO RAISE CHILDREN, IT'S
ALWAYS A NASTY EDGE TO IT
DOESN'T IT?
THE XHEFTS DO THIS.
THEY CALL AT THIS TIME CHILD
TAX.
AND I REMEMBER THINKING LIKE,
THERE'S SOMETHING VERY NASTY IN
THE SOCIETY WHEN YOU START
TALKING ABOUT CHILDREN AS BEING
LIKE A TAX ON YOU.
>> Kat: AREN'T THEY?
>> Douglas: WELL, YOU COULD LOOK
AT IT LIKE THAT.
YOU COULD THINK WHEN I DIE I'LL
LEAVE AN EXTRA 300,000 BUCKS IN
MY BANK ACCOUNT AND THAT WILL
SHOW THEM.
BUT, ON THE OTHER HAND, YOU'VE
GOT KIDS.
YOU KNOW, IT'S KIND OF POSITIVE
>> Kat: I GUESS.
THE THING THAT SCARES ME IS YOU
DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE GOING TO
LIKE THEM OR NOT UNTIL THEY'RE
ALREADY HERE.
>> Tyrus: THEY GROW ON YOU.
>> Kat: I'LL TALK ABOUT THAT
WITH MY THERAPIST IN A COUPLE
DAYS DAGEN YOU'RE A BUSINESS
BANKER WILL THIS CONTINUE TO GET
WORSE?
>> Dagen: OH, YEAH.
YOU WANT NASTY EDGE?
I'LL GO NASTY EDGE.
I GAVE A BOTTLE OF PERFECT YAY
THE FINGER AT CVS THE OTHER DAY
BECAUSE IT WAS SO EXPENSIVE.
AND THE MANAGER GOES YEAH,
SHAKING HIS HEAD.
THAT'S HOW BAD INFLATION IS.
THIS IS, WHEN I THINK ABOUT
HAVING KIDS, YOU KNOW, THESE
STATS ONLY RUN THROUGH AGE 17.
SO THERE'S ANOTHER -- I'M NOT
GOING TO PICK ON LINCOLN, SO
MAKE THIS A GIRL IN MY ANALOGY.
>> Kat: NAMED LINCOLN.
>> Dagen: YEAH [LAUGHTER].
>> Dagen: YOU'VE GOT A KID,
DAUGHTER, COLLEGE, QUARTER OF A
MILLION DOLLARS.
SHE GETS PREGNANT BY A WAITER
SHE MET AT SHUCKERS TWO DAYS
AFTER SHE GRADUATES.
SHE GETS KNOCKED UP, MARRIES
HIM, MARRIES HIM, THREE KIDS,
SHE EVENTUALLY LEAVES HIM
BECAUSE HIS JOB INVOLVES
COLLECTING TREASURE WITH A METAL
DETECTOR ON THE BEACH.
SO HE'S NOT REALLY CARRYING HIS
WEIGHT.
SHE MOVES BACK INTO YOUR HOUSE
AT AGE 35 WITH THE THREE KIDS,
AND YOU'RE GOING WIND UP TAKING
A DIRT NAP BEFORE YOU EVER GET
TO RETIRE.
>> Kat: UNLESS SHE GETS A JOB ON
MTV.
>> Dagen: OR MSNBC.
>> Kat: YEAH, TEEN MOM.
THERE ARE SOME EMPLOYMENT
OPTIONS THERE.
I DON'T KNOW IF ANY OF THEM ARE
GOOD, KIDS.
KIDS DON'T WATCH THIS.
>> UP